the bills Republican critics include
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham he
said in a statement if this proposal
were to become law it would be
devastating to our state's economy which
relies on this immigrant workforce the
president endorsed the plan while Senate
Republicans are struggling with other
items like health care and tax reform
Graham South Carolina colleague
Republican senator Tim Scott is with us
now from Capitol Hill he is a member of
the Senate Finance Committee and the
committee on health education labor and
pensions Senator Scott good morning good
morning good to lay out what your
problem is with this proposal
well I've end of the day the reality of
it is that our competitors other
countries using merit-based system so
that's not a bad idea it's actually a
good idea the reality of it is however
that the greatest subunit in our country
is the family so having family cohesion
is important I think the problems within
our legal immigration system isn't the
number so if there's needs for reforms
we should reform the systems that need
to be reformed but the reality of it is
that it has less to do with the number
and more to do with reforms in South
Carolina there are a lot of jobs that go
unfilled because we can't find the
workers to do that job those jobs
how would you reform the immigration
well there's a need for a hybrid system
if you look at where we have the largest
holes in our economy our stem is a major
part of it that science technology
engineering math we need more workers in
that space they're also our agriculture
if you visit a farm in South Carolina
and you'll find that they are desperate
for workers so we need a hybrid system
that matches our economy with the labor
that's coming in from other countries
and at the same time my sister-in-law is
a great example of someone who
immigrated from Korea I helped create my
nephew who I call the heir to the sky
throne I wanted to make sure that folks
have an opportunity to assimilate to
what it means to be an American and so
what we should look for are hybrids
where we meet our economic needs and at
the same time allow for family cohesion
to be what it always has been which is
the anchor of the American Society well
agriculture and tourism are both
industries that are important to your
home state and I think that's what
you're talking about being impacted but
when you're talking about putting a
preference towards skilled
workers this is something that Canada
and Australia have implemented is there
a way to get at that idea without
cutting the number of green cards in
half yeah the number is a whole
different subject that I am NOT on the
same page having a merit-based system so
that we have the workers necessary to
grow our economy is an absolute
necessity it's essential we can do both
you can have a system that rewards merit
based in the areas where we need it and
at the same time allows for family
cohesion to continue and I'm a big
proponent for us to sit down at the
table figure out which way is up because
right now we have a lot of issues that
we haven't figured that out on and and
if we can figure that out head in that
direction so for me up is more workers
who meet the high demands that we have
within our economy rather that high
demand is STEM engineering jobs or
rather that high demand is in
agriculture or tourism in my state we
need to match the folks coming into the
country with the jobs that we need and
we certainly should have a merit-based
system but at the same time there's
nothing wrong with making sure that we
create access for family members who are
already here as long as we do it right
and that's the legal immigration system
has not been the focus nor has it been
the problem for us for the last several
years senator you're heading home on
August recess what are you going to tell
your constituents about plans for tax
reform we haven't seen specifics yet
well there's a lot of conversation I've
been a part of conversations with the
white house with the House of
Representatives and certainly on the
Finance Committee the one thing that all
faria or three of us have in common
is a need for us to lower taxes for the
average worker the truth is that while
the stock market is hitting new highs it
seems every day the average worker has
not seen an increase in their pay one of
the ways that we get increases in their
own take-home money is not to take it
out of their paychecks
that's what tax cuts should focus on are
those folks in the middle income
brackets that haven't seen a raise in
almost a decade
what is it failure to get a health care
reform to
replace Obamacare say about the
Republican Party Charlie says health
care has a very difficult conversation
and it's hard to get 52 votes it's hard
to get 52 members on the same page and
frankly we lost 2-1 more than we could
afford we were at 49 and set of 50 that
was a big deal for us and frankly it's a
big deal for the nation a huge deal for
health care the reality of it is that we
have to find a way Abama care is
imploding we have the final way to fix
it and the next conversation will start
with the individual market where the
pain is the most because a market is
small only about 20 million Americans in
that market about million and a half of
those Americans have complex serious
diseases that will need some type of
reinsurance or health care one quick
follow us it likely to take place
after the midterm elections are before
absolutely before as a matter of fact in
South Carolina we're looking at a 33
percent rate increase this year on top
of 120 percent rate increases over the
last four years we can't wait for
another election cycle for us to start
fixing the problems that are really
causing so many Americans pain suffering
and a loss of their paychecks senator
Scott thank you so much for joining us
this morning yes sir have a great day